Salut, moi, c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Ravi de vous retrouver en ce mois de décembre. J'ai encore une fois pris une semaine de retard et j'en suis désolé.
Les choses sont très compliquées pour moi en ce moment. J'ai beaucoup de boulot, des interviews en pleine pandémie, beaucoup de choses à gérer, dont un déménagement d'ailleurs, puisque je vais bientôt m'installer à Ixelles.
Comme je l'avais annoncé la dernière fois, aujourd'hui, on parle de politique belge avec Dave Sinardet, qui est politologue et flamand, histoire d'avoir un regard différent de ce qu'on entend d'habitude dans la presse francophone.
Alors, clairement, il y en a parmi vous que ça ne va pas du tout intéresser. Je pense en particulier aux gens qui habitent à l'étranger.
Et du coup, pour vous, je sors également cette semaine un épisode bonus où on parle de préhistoire et de patriarcat.
On retrouve tout de suite Dave Sinardet. C'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Dave Sinardet. Dave Sinardet, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Dave Sinardet, vous êtes professeur en sciences politiques à la VUB et à Saint-Louis, principalement à la VUB. Vous êtes spécialisé en fédéralisme, en nationalisme et en politique belge.
Et on vous voit souvent dans les médias, principalement presse écrite, par exemple pour votre chronique dans De Standaard, Voorbij de Grens.
Et auparavant, vous avez pu écrire pour Le Soir, pour De Morgen, pour De Tijd, pour La Libre, et cetera, voilà.
Vous êtes un habitué des médias pour commenter l'actualité politique. Vous me recevez aujourd'hui dans le Palais royal à Anvers.
Vous avez eu la gentillesse de me faire visiter. Donc c'est apparemment un lieu qui a accueilli, vous me disiez, Guillaume Ier, Léopold II et Napoléon.
Vous m'avez fait visiter la chambre de Napoléon. Donc voilà, nous sommes dans un lieu très particulier. Alors, on va tout de suite, voilà, vous présenter un petit peu.
Je dirais que vous vous distinguez de
vos confrères dans le monde académique, dans le monde des médias pour commenter l'actualité politique, dans le sens que vous êtes vraiment des deux côtés de la frontière linguistique, donc autant
côté universitaire, puisque je disais, vous donnez cours à la VUB et à Saint-Louis, mais aussi dans les médias, puisque, voilà, vous avez fait des chroniques des deux côtés de la frontière linguistique.
Dans vos chroniques, vous défendez des idées plutôt fédéralistes, plutôt pour, voilà, un côté pro-Belgique, je dirais, plutôt que très régionaliste, très séparatiste.
Je vous vois hésiter un petit peu. Vous allez me dire tout de suite si je me trompe.
C'est déjà une question très large pour commencer, effectivement. Donc je travaille entre autres sur le nationalisme et sur le rôle de l'État-nation.
Bon, mon analyse, mais bon, d'autres peuvent avoir une autre analyse, hein, c'est, voilà, c'est le débat académique, mais mon analyse, c'est qu'aujourd'hui,
l'État-nation comme centre de la décision politique n'a plus la capacité de réguler un tas d'évolutions sociétales, économiques et autres que dans le passé.
On peut le regretter ou pas, mais c'est le cas, hein.
Si aujourd'hui, on veut vraiment avoir un impact sur le climat, par exemple, mais aussi sur le terrorisme, sur l'immigration,
mais même sur la justice fiscale, comme État-nation, on a encore très peu de leviers pour vraiment intervenir sur tous ces sujets, hein.
On ne peut pas réguler l'immigration, voilà, comme gouvernement national belge. On ne peut pas arrêter le réchauffement climatique comme gouvernement national français tout seul.
On ne peut pas non plus, dans le cadre européen où on est dans une économie globalisée, par exemple,
certes, le gouvernement belge peut dire : « On diminue l'impôt sur les sociétés », mais à ce moment-là, les Pays-Bas vont dire : « Ah oui, on va faire la même chose »,
parce que sinon, les multinationales vont se déplacer.
Et donc voilà, si on veut vraiment avoir une politique fiscale cohérente, à nouveau, c'est quelque chose qu'il faudrait plutôt envisager au niveau européen.
Donc, à nouveau, qu'on le veuille ou non, l'État-nation n'a plus vraiment l'impact qu'il avait dans le passé. Et donc, j'ai aussi suivi fortement, parce que pour moi, c'est aussi une question de nationalisme, tout le débat sur le Brexit.
Je comprends beaucoup de gens qui votent pour le Brexit quand les Brexiteers leur disent : « Il faut reprendre le contrôle ».
Parce que beaucoup de gens ont effectivement le sentiment qu'ils ont perdu le contrôle sur le processus démocratique. Ils ont même raison parce que, voilà, dans un monde globalisé, c'est très difficile.
Mais la réponse des Brexiteers et d'autres nationalistes de dire : « Il faut retourner à l'État-nation parce que là, c'est take back control.
On va à nouveau être comme on était dans le passé, le bel empire britannique ou le bel État-nation français, allemand, voire belge ou flamand », c'est malheureusement essayer de vendre une illusion aux gens.
La seule solution, à nouveau, qu'on le veuille ou non, c'est plus de gouvernance européenne transnationale.
Et donc, dans ce cadre-là, aller créer de nouveaux États-nations encore plus petits, comme par exemple la Flandre ou l'Écosse ou la Catalogne, dans ce cadre plus global que je viens de dessiner, je crois que c'est assez absurde.
Donc voilà, donc je suis assez critique contre le nationalisme parce que je crois que ça ne va pas résoudre les grands problèmes d'aujourd'hui d'essayer de retourner à un État-nation mythique, à une illusion, finalement, nationale.
Tout ça, c'est plutôt particulier pour une personnalité flamande-
Oui, non, c'est clair qu'effectivement, je suis assez présent des deux côtés de la frontière linguistique, comme vous le disiez déjà dans mon affiliation universitaire.
D'ailleurs, pour rire, je dis parfois que je,
sur ce point-là, je transgresse déjà au moins deux des grands clivages qui ont traversé l'histoire belge, hein, puisque je suis professeur tant dans une université flamande laïque et une université catholique francophone.
D'ailleurs, je suis aussi toujours du côté de la minorité, on pourrait dire, la minorité laïque du côté flamand et la minorité catholique du côté francophone, historiquement, en tout cas, hein.
OK.
Donc voilà. Et d'ailleurs, le cours que je donne à Saint-Louis, hein, pour encore un peu aller plus loin, peut-être dans le surréalisme un peu belge, le cours à Saint-Louis, c'est en néerlandais-
Ah oui, d'accord
...dans le programme multilingue.
Je ne savais pas ça.
Et en même temps, la moitié de mes cours à la VUB sont en anglais
OK
Et donc si ça continue comme ça à la VUB, avec les cours en anglais, ce sera seulement à une université francophone que je pourrais encore donner des cours en néerlandais dans ma langue maternelle. Donc voilà.
Vous expliquez, vous êtes du côté de la minorité, vous avez un profil plutôt particulier. Comment vous expliquez ça ?
Bah, être actif des deux côtés de la frontière linguistique, bon, je trouve ça assez normal finalement, puisque voilà, je travaille,
entre autres sur la politique belge, mais aussi sur le fédéralisme et le nationalisme qui sont quand même aussi des thématiques, voilà, pas seulement importantes en Belgique du tout, mais quand même aussi importantes en Belgique.
Et donc de ce point de vue, cela me semblerait assez bizarre de se limiter à un côté de la frontière linguistique. Si je veux bien comprendre la Belgique dans toutes ses facettes et notamment la politique belge,
voilà, je dois être présent des deux côtés.
Je dois avoir aussi des contacts des deux côtés.
Honnêtement, voilà, je ne comprends pas toujours très bien que certains de mes collègues pour qui j'ai beaucoup d'estime, mais qu'eux se limitent vraiment à un côté de la frontière linguistique.
Parfois, ils ne parlent pas ou du tout ou pas très bien
l'autre langue nationale. Bon, c'est quand même difficile de bien comprendre les subtilités, par exemple, d'un discours politique ou d'un discours médiatique flamand si on ne parle pas du tout le néerlandais.
Et inversement, bien sûr, pour des collègues néerlandophones. Donc ça me semble en fait être l'évidence pour quelqu'un qui travaille sur la politique belge notamment,
d'être actif des deux côtés de la frontière linguistique.
Et aussi, j'ai toujours trouvé ça assez important. Voilà pourquoi, s'il y a un média francophone, par exemple, ou un podcasteur francophone, comme dans ce cas-ci, me demande
de m'interviewer, donner une analyse sur la Belgique ou sur le fédéralisme, pourquoi est-ce que je refuserais ?
Je ne veux pas être comme certains politiques
qui sont dans un gouvernement fédéral, qui prennent des décisions pour tous les Belges et qui refusent de parler à l'opinion publique de l'autre communauté sur laquelle leurs décisions ont néanmoins quand même un impact.
Bon, chez moi, c'est même pas le cas. Je ne prends pas des décisions qui ont un impact sur les francophones, mais je travaille sur des thématiques qui sont pertinentes tout autant pour des francophones en Belgique que des néerlandophones.
Donc voilà, d'ailleurs, je réponds aussi régulièrement à des invitations de médias étrangers. Donc voilà, tout ça me semble assez évident, mais c'est vrai que dans le contexte belge qu'on connaît,
c'est peut-être quand même assez spécifique.
Je suis peut-être une créature un peu rare dans ce sens-là. Même si ces dernières années, j'ai quand même remarqué qu'il y a
il y a de plus en plus de figures qui, commentateurs, journalistes et autres qui transgressent la frontière linguistique.
On va en reparler. Créature rare, comme vous le disiez, mais donc
sans même comprendre qu'on puisse,
avoir une approche différente, vous ne comprenez pas vraiment les personnes, vos confrères qui ont une approche très, voilà, très régionaliste, soit très flamande, soit très wallonne ?
Bah, c'est pas nécessairement régionaliste dans le sens où, voilà, on peut très bien, par exemple, être régionaliste en termes d'idéologie sur, voilà, sur le futur de la Belgique, qu'il faut plus régionaliser ou qu'il faut même séparer.
En même temps, on peut toujours quand même aussi défendre, par exemple, cette position des deux côtés de la frontière linguistique.
D'ailleurs, si vous voulez arriver à une vraie régionalisation, c'est mieux de défendre le point de vue des deux côtés parce que voilà, il faudra prendre la décision des deux côtés.
C'est ça. Très bien. Voilà, mais donc je note que c'est pour vous très naturel d'être cette créature rare et que vous ne comprenez pas vraiment qu'on puisse, voilà, faire différemment.
On le disait, vous êtes professeur de sciences politiques à la VUB et à Saint-Louis. Vous faites aussi le choix d'apparaître régulièrement dans les médias.
Est-ce que pour vous, ça fait partie d'une démarche, je dirais, qui est elle-même politique, qui est elle-même militante ?
Est-ce que quand vous apparaissez dans les médias, vous cherchez à défendre
un point de vue, une démarche ? Quel est votre objectif quand vous écrivez, par exemple, pour De Standaard ou pour d'autres médias ou que vous intervenez sur la VRT ?
Bah tout d'abord, je trouve que pour un académique, c'est très important d'être présent dans le débat public, hein.
J'ai toujours trouvé cela.
Par exemple, quand, voilà, quand la Belgique bat tous les records
de longévité de formation de gouvernement, hein, comme on l'a fait il y a 10 ans, quand on parle, d'ailleurs aussi dans d'autres pays, d'une scission de la Belgique, etc.
Bon, à ce moment-là, je crois que c'est important pour un académique qui travaille sur ces questions de pas seulement dialoguer avec ses confrères dans un congrès de sciences politiques à Reykjavik, par exemple,
mais aussi d'être présent, voilà, dans le débat public en Belgique, à nouveau des deux côtés de la frontière linguistique, sur ces questions-là, hein.
Donc je trouve que les académiques ont aussi vraiment un droit, mais même un devoir aussi, de jouer un rôle sociétal, de jouer un rôle dans le débat public.
Personnellement, c'est toujours comme ça que j'ai conçu aussi ma fonction, même si l'évolution du monde académique va quand même un peu dans un autre sens, notamment en Flandre, hein.
Quand vous voulez faire carrière dans le monde académique aujourd'hui, c'est surtout des publications scientifiques internationales, hein,
d'une certaine catégorie spécifique d'ailleurs, qu'il faut rechercher, voilà, les fonds de recherche, etc.
Je trouve ça très important aussi, évidemment hein, mais je ne trouve pas que c'est le seul critère sur lequel on doit évaluer un académique.
Je trouve aussi qu'il faut vraiment stimuler les académiques pour rendre leurs connaissances, leurs résultats de recherche, leurs analyses, donc les rendre publics pour un public aussi large que possible.
Donc moi, je serais personnellement aussi, je ne serais pas heureux si j'étais cet académique de la tour d'ivoire, hein, qui, voilà, comme je disais, qui dialogue qu'avec ses confrères.
En même temps, je serais aussi malheureux si j'étais, par exemple, journaliste rue de la Loi, parce que
étant tous les jours focalisé, voilà, sur les petits jeux politiciens, et le waan van de dag, comme on dit en néerlandais, hein, donc un peu le
La folie du jour littéralement.
Donc je suis assez, voilà, la combinaison d'être d'un côté vraiment dans le monde académique, de pouvoir écrire des choses un peu plus intemporelles, des analyses plus profondes,
de faire de la recherche, etc., d'un côté, mais de l'autre côté aussi de combiner ça avec
vraiment une présence sur le terrain, aussi des vrais contacts.
Parce que je crois que comme académique, bien sûr, on analyse d'abord, par exemple, la politique belge sur base de, voilà, des résultats de recherche, etc., et sur base de théories.
Mais pas seulement sur base de ça non plus. Il faut aussi confronter ces théories avec, voilà, une connaissance du terrain, des contacts et des conversations avec des politiques, des journalistes, etc.
Donc pour moi, ça a toujours été évident de combiner ces deux aspects-là. Donc ça, c'est un élément.
L'autre élément, c'est qu'effectivement, je trouve aussi qu'un académique doit jouer ce rôle parfois aussi en défendant certaines positions, hein.
D'ailleurs, c'est ce que font la plupart des académiques, hein. Quand vous regardez les économistes, ils ne se limitent pas à faire des analyses de la politique économique.
Non, ils disent : voilà, ça, c'est une mauvaise réforme fiscale, il faudrait faire ça, il faudrait pas faire ça, etc. Bon, d'ailleurs, quand vous mettez quatre économistes ensemble, vous avez six opinions.
Même chose, enfin, c'est peut-être moins le cas avec les politologues, mais ça peut être le cas aussi.
Et donc là aussi, si vous travaillez, je trouve que sur les questions sur lesquelles vous travaillez, vous avez à nouveau aussi le droit et même le devoir de développer une certaine vision et d'expliquer votre vision.
Pas en disant que c'est la seule vision possible, mais en tout cas que c'est, voilà, votre vision sur base d'une analyse de la problématique.
Donc, par exemple, moi, je travaille sur le nationalisme, je travaille sur le fédéralisme.
Voilà, j'ai développé au cours des années une certaine vision sur, voilà, l'État-nation, le futur de l'État-nation, sur, voilà, quels sont les modèles
de fédéralisme qui fonctionnent mieux ou qui fonctionnent moins bien, comment est-ce qu'on pourrait faire mieux fonctionner le fédéralisme belge, mais aussi la démocratie belge, est-ce qu'il faut impliquer plus les citoyens, etc., etc.
Je trouve que, voilà, comme académique, comme intellectuel qui travaille sur ces matières, je dois aussi avoir une certaine vision sur la question.
En même temps, je trouve qu'il faut rester très neutre en termes d'affiliation partisane. Ça, c'est autre chose.
Donc j'essaie, quand je fais vraiment des analyses politiques sur, voilà, sur des partis politiques,
ou sur des fonctionnements d'un gouvernement, là, j'essaie de rester le plus objectif possible et pas d'être tout le temps en train de défendre tel parti
ou un autre parti, etc.
Donc ça, c'est autre chose,
mais on va peut-être y revenir sur la particratie. Je trouve que c'est aussi important d'avoir des voix qui sont un peu indépendantes de, voilà, de la logique partisane en Belgique.
On va effectivement approcher tous ces sujets. En tout cas, ce qui me frappe dans ce que vous me dites, c'est vraiment, voilà, une passion pour la chose politique
qui explique, voilà, votre démarche dans les médias, qui explique votre démarche
académique, ce que vous expliquiez sur le rôle que vous essayez de jouer dans le débat public.
En octobre dernier, vous disiez justement dans une chronique pour De Standaard,
vous le disiez en néerlandais, mais j'ai traduit en français, vous le disiez : « Ces derniers mois, je me suis demandé si la politique me fascinait encore suffisamment. » Est-ce que c'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui ?
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Comment est-ce que vous expliquez que, voilà, le Dave Sinardet passionné que vous me décrivez depuis le début de cet entretien, début octobre,
pas sûr d'être encore vraiment passionné par ce qui se passe en Belgique ?
Bah en fait, début octobre, ça allait mieux.
OK.
Donc j'ai écrit-
Oui, c'est ça. Vous décriviez donc le long processus de formation d'un gouvernement fédéral, cette dernière année, ouais.
Ouais, ouais. Bon, c'est surtout la période entre mai et août où là, un peu, je sentais que je commençais à décrocher.
Et ça avait bien sûr tout à voir avec cette longue formation de gouvernement hein, où il était quand même assez clair que
si au moins cette longue formation de gouvernement avait à voir avec des vrais débats idéologiques et des vrais, 'fin,
des projets de société complètement opposés qui s'affrontaient, alors ça aurait encore été, voilà, intéressant et on aurait pu se dire : voilà, c'est normal que ça dure aussi longtemps.
Mais en fait, soyons honnêtes, c'était pas l'essentiel de la raison pour laquelle on a pris presque 500 jours à nouveau pour former un gouvernement en Belgique.
En fait, quand on regarde, par exemple, le fameux projet N-VA PS qui s'est finalement développé l'été dernier, hein, ensemble avec le CDH, le CD&V et le SP.A, la fameuse bulle de cinq.
Et quand on compare ça à l'accord de gouvernement Vivaldi, en fait, les différences ne sont pas énormes, hein. Notamment quand on regarde la politique socioéconomique, c'est plus ou moins la même chose.
Bon, il y a une différence sur le communautaire, mais même là, vu que le CD&V dans la Vivaldi, il a quand même aussi poussé un peu dans la même direction.
Donc, en fait, voilà, c'était quand même largement une question de perception, cette longue période de formation de gouvernement.
Tel parti ne voulait pas aller avec un autre. Donc concrètement, voilà, le PS voulait pendant un an pas aller avec la N-VA parce que voilà.
Tandis que, moi, j'ai dit depuis le début qu'ils pouvaient très bien se retrouver. D'ailleurs, voilà, on en a fait la preuve cet été dernier.
Bon, pour la N-VA, c'était pas difficile avec les écologistes et inversement. Pas parce que, voilà, à nouveau, les programmes étaient si difficiles à marier, mais surtout parce que, voilà, la perception aurait été problématique.
Et donc, on était quand même dans une logique de jeu partisan. Aussi de voilà, on ne peut pas former un gouvernement maintenant, ah non, parce que Paul Magnette n'est pas encore président du PS.
Et donc voilà, il faudra attendre. Ah, ensuite, Paul Magnette est président du PS. Oui, mais là, on ne sait pas qui va être le président du CD&V, donc on ne peut pas avancer.
Finalement, il y a un président du CD&V. Ah oui, mais au VLD, il faut attendre maintenant encore cinq mois parce qu'on ne sait pas si ça va être Lachaert ou Tommelein.
Bon, tout ça, je peux expliquer ça rationnellement, hein, qu'effectivement, il y a des problèmes au sein des partis, etc.
Et que pour ça, on ne peut pas avancer. Mais à un certain moment, je me suis dit : Bon, je peux au public essayer d'expliquer pourquoi ça dure aussi longtemps.
Mais alors, je risque,
en expliquant aussi, de légitimer cette situation. Et là, je trouvais ça quand même un problème, parce que ça peut être très logique quand on est dans la petite bulle de la rue de la Loi : Oui, mais il faut attendre la présidence du VLD.
On ne peut pas expliquer ça,
à onze millions de Belges, en fait. Et d'ailleurs, dans d'autres pays, voilà, il y a aussi des petits problèmes partisans, mais là, quand même, on se dit à un certain moment, voilà, il faut former un gouvernement.
Et donc, voilà, notamment quand tout ce cirque, si je puis dire, a repris en mai, oui, je sentais que j'arrivais moins qu'avant à me motiver pour qu'on suive encore ça dans tous les détails.
Oui, maintenant, celui-là a fait une déclaration et l'autre n'est pas content.
Donc c'est ce qu'on appelle, de manière générale, les petits jeux de politiciens. On parlait il y a un instant de la particratie.
Ben, c'est tout à fait ça. C'est
vers la fin des négociations, peu de temps avant qu'on aboutisse à un accord, il y avait notamment la personnalité de Georges-Louis Bouchez, qui posait beaucoup question, et les autres négociateurs ne l'aiment pas trop.
Et on aimerait bien s'en débarrasser. On va demander à Sophie Wilmès de venir aussi. Il y a ce côté très, c'est un problème très personnel entre des gens.
Mh.
Et les onze millions de Belges sont moyennement concernés par ces problèmes-là.
Et donc voilà, il y a une énorme distance entre les représentants, les partis et, voilà, les électeurs directement.
Est-ce que ça, c'est spécifiquement belge ? Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on voit dans d'autres pays ? Et qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait mettre en place pour échapper à ça ?
Puisque c'est très symptomatique d'un système de coalition et d'un pays aussi très divisé, voilà, politiquement, de manière communautaire, etc.
Donc, comme vous le disiez il y a un instant, on peut l'expliquer, on peut comprendre que tout ça finisse par arriver.
On a un peu du mal à imaginer même comment on pourrait échapper à ce débouché-là.
Bah, commençons par dire que, voilà, les partis politiques sont bien sûr des acteurs importants dans chaque démocratie, donc ce n'est pas nécessairement un problème.
Et donc, ils jouent un rôle dans, voilà, dans beaucoup de pays.
En même temps, le rôle central des partis politiques est quand même encore un peu plus fort en Belgique que dans la plupart des autres pays, parce qu'on parle parfois donc de particratie.
Bon, ça peut sembler un concept assez péjoratif, mais c'est aussi un concept qui est utilisé en sciences politiques pour dénommer un système politique où les partis sont vraiment très, très puissants, où ils sont vraiment au centre,
pas seulement de la politique, mais aussi de la société à travers des nominations politiques, etc., etc.
Et ça, on peut quand même dire qu'effectivement, la Belgique est probablement un des pays les plus particratiques en Europe, avec notamment l'Italie, par exemple.
Et ça pose à un certain moment quand même quelques problèmes. Et on l'a vu dans cette formation de gouvernement.
Bon, à nouveau, ce n'est pas non plus possible d'opposer complètement intérêt de parti et intérêt général.
C'est normal pour des partis politiques de toujours aussi tenir compte d'intérêts de parti. Mais en Belgique, on va quand même assez loin dans cette logique.
Et c'est ce qu'on a vu, notamment, donc pendant ces très longs cinq cents jours. Qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire ?
Bah, je crois qu'il y a différentes choses qu'on pourrait faire. Impliquer peut-être un peu plus d'autres acteurs, par exemple les citoyens.
Moi, j'ai aussi toujours été partisan d'une démocratie plus délibérative et plus participative, donc où on essaye d'impliquer plus les citoyens dans la prise de décision politique.
Je ne dis pas qu'il faut remplacer la démocratie représentative par une démocratie participative, bien sûr, mais on peut quand même donner aux citoyens une place plus importante.
Par exemple, voilà, on peut organiser des forums de réflexion sur base de citoyens tirés au sort sur certaines thématiques sociétales importantes.
Dans d'autres pays, on l'a fait souvent avec des conséquences intéressantes. Par exemple, en Irlande, sur des questions qui divisaient aussi très fortement, comme le mariage homosexuel ou l'avortement,
où là, à nouveau, les partis politiques n'osaient pas avancer dans la recherche d'une solution, voilà, consensuelle.
En fait, en organisant des forums avec des citoyens tirés au sort, on a avancé sur ces discussions.
On a aussi des discussions plus rationnelles, aussi, qui allaient au-delà des clivages typiques entre, voilà, entre catholiques et autres.
Bon, ça, c'est un exemple. Je pourrais vous en citer beaucoup.
Et donc ça, c'est peut-être une bonne chose, dans l'accord du gouvernement Vivaldi, on dit maintenant que, par exemple, sur la réforme de l'État, on veut effectivement plus impliquer les citoyens.
Ce ne serait pas une mauvaise chose, parce que s'il y a un dossier en Belgique qui est vraiment dominé totalement par la particratie, c'est bien la réforme de l'État.
Comment est négociée une réforme de l'État en Belgique ? Ben en fait, c'est les présidents de partis qui se mettent ensemble
avec un petit cercle de collaborateurs, de sherpas, qui sont encore les seuls en Belgique à encore connaître tous les détails de la loi de financement ou de la distribution de compétences, parce que pour le reste, c'est devenu si,
si complexe et si compliqué que
il n'y a plus personne qui comprend, même pas dans le monde politique.
Et voilà. Et donc finalement, après des centaines de jours dans un château et beaucoup de crises et de crisettes, il y a une nouvelle réforme de l'État.
Et, voilà, ensuite, on constate que c'est encore plus complexe qu'avant. Donc ce ne serait peut-être pas mal d'aérer un petit peu, de laisser effectivement réfléchir les citoyens sur la question.
Malheureusement et bizarrement, l'accord Vivaldi
dit d'un côté, voilà, on veut une réflexion sans tabou sur la réforme de l'État, on veut impliquer les citoyens, d'ailleurs aussi les experts, les académiques, ça, c'est encore meilleur, bien sûr.
Je dis ça à moitié pour rire.
Mais en même temps, ils disent quand même : Ah, mais en fait, sur la régionalisation des soins de santé, qui est un des éléments clés probablement d'une nouvelle réforme de l'État, là, on a déjà décidé nous-mêmes qu'il faudrait régionaliser.
Donc c'est un peu bizarre de dire : on veut impliquer les citoyens dans un débat sans tabou sur l'avenir du pays. Mais là, sur un des morceaux quand même très importants, on a déjà pris la décision nous-mêmes.
Bon, disons que, 'fin, je peux expliquer la logique politique derrière. C'est la N-VA qui a voulu ça.
C'est les autres qui ont voulu le débat sans tabou. Et donc on arrive à un débat sans tabou avec un tabou.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Mais enfin, en tout cas, c'est bien quand même d'impliquer plus les citoyens. Et d'ailleurs aussi les experts. Ça, c'est
un autre problème peut-être, en Belgique, comparé à d'autres pays, où on implique généralement aussi moins les experts dans la prise des décisions politiques.
Pour la formation de,
de gouvernement, ça peut peut-être aussi aider,
aider un petit peu, mais bon, on peut quand même difficilement imaginer, enfin moi, en tout cas, peut-être d'autres,
d'autres imaginent ça, mais pour moi, ça me semble plus difficile de vraiment impliquer les citoyens dans un processus de gouvernement, de,
de formation de gouvernement.
Ça, c'est encore autre chose. Là, je penserais plutôt à d'autres méthodes. Je crois qu'il y a un grand problème de procrastination dans l'élite politique belge.
D'ailleurs, je suis un peu expert en procrastination moi-même, donc je reconnais le problème, c'est les politiques.
On attendait aussi le fait que, voilà, des acteurs comme Didier Reynders, Charles Michel, etc., devaient partir vers l'Europe et abandonner leurs responsabilités au niveau fédéral.
Donc il y avait effectivement ce côté très, de nouveau, voilà, de, de...
Oui, on a le temps.
Voilà, on a le temps et on prioritise notre propre réalité, notre propre... un truc très logistique plutôt que-
Oui
...l'urgence de former un gouvernement fédéral. On a le temps, ça, on fera ça plus tard.
Et donc il faudrait un moyen de pression, je crois, pour accélérer la formation de gouvernement.
Vous avez une idée ?
Oui, il y a différentes pistes possibles. Donc, on pourrait adopter le système qui existe notamment en Espagne ou en Israël, où on l'a inscrit dans la Constitution que
s'il n'y a pas encore de nouveau gouvernement après six mois après les élections, on retourne automatiquement aux urnes.
Le but n'est pas en premier lieu de retourner vraiment aux urnes. Le but est que ce soit un moyen de pression sur les politiques qui ne veulent pas retourner aux urnes et qui donc doivent accélérer un petit peu la formation du gouvernement.
Autre moyen, considéré peut-être un peu comme poujadiste par certains, mais je ne suis pas d'accord avec cette critique, c'est qu'on pourrait aussi dire, voilà, après six mois, le financement des partis diminue progressivement.
Il faut quand même savoir qu'on a un des systèmes de financement de partis en Europe, quand on compare avec d'autres pays, les partis politiques reçoivent vraiment beaucoup d'argent.
Et bon, il y a des bonnes raisons, mais en même temps, voilà, s'ils ne remplissent pas un de leurs devoirs qui est de former un gouvernement, on pourrait progressivement diminuer.
Par exemple, je ne sais pas, après six mois, on commence avec 10 %, après sept mois, c'est 20 %, 30 %. Finalement, on a quand même des allocations de chômage dégressives, parce qu'on dit : voilà, OK, le chômage, c'est un droit,
mais si vous, vous êtes au chômage trop longtemps, voilà, on a aussi le droit de diminuer votre allocation.
OK, ça, c'est une logique qu'on peut suivre. Mais alors, pourquoi est-ce que la logique ne s'appliquerait pas aussi aux partis ?
Donc justement, la réponse à cette question, c'est parce que c'est le parti qui décide. C'est le parti qui vote à la Chambre, qui n'ont pas forcément envie de se mettre eux-mêmes ce genre de pression.
Donc ça ne risque pas d'arriver, si ?
Ça, c'est un des grands problèmes, bien sûr, qu'effectivement, chaque réforme, que ce soit une réforme électorale ou autre, bute bien sûr toujours sur l'analyse des partis politiques.
Est-ce que ça va être dans notre intérêt de-
Ouais, c'est ça
...de soutenir cette réforme ? Mais bon, ici, avec cette proposition, 'fin, la proposition, effectivement, du financement, ça me semble assez difficile de trouver une majorité des deux tiers pour cela.
Le retour aux urnes après six mois, là, il y a peut-être quand même un-- Je crois qu'il y a quand même aussi un sentiment collectif chez beaucoup de partis politiques et beaucoup de parlementaires que, voilà,
qu'il y a quand même vraiment eu un problème dans cette formation de gouvernement et qu'il faut trouver des moyens et qu'un moyen de pression n'est peut-être pas une mauvaise chose.
Mais voilà, je suis aussi assez sceptique sur, voilà, est-ce que tout le monde sera d'accord sur une solution ?
Bon, il faudra voir.
Parce que, oui, parce que
là, c'est la première fois que j'entends une telle idée, voilà,
ici, dans votre bouche. Je n'entends pas vraiment les acteurs politiques parler de ça dans le débat public, dire : oui, il faudrait vraiment qu'on mette une deadline sur la formation d'un gouvernement.
Donc ça, ça me paraît être-
Il y a certains politiques qui ont quand même défendu des idées similaires.
Doucement, discrètement, légèrement. Et ça, ça n'est pas quelque chose qui a de l'ampleur pour l'instant, on est bien d'accord.
Bah l'accord du gouvernement aussi prévoit quand même de rechercher des méthodes pour justement éviter une nouvelle formation aussi longue.
Mais on voit que même au sein de la coalition actuelle du gouvernement De Croo, voilà, il y a effectivement des visions différentes.
Mais ce que-- 'fin, il y a une conscientisation du problème, déjà.
Ça, ça s'est avéré, ouais.
Ça, c'est déjà le premier pas, au moins.
C'est ça. Bon alors, quand on parle de la situation politique aujourd'hui en Belgique, il est évident qu'il faut parler des résultats des élections fédérales en Flandre en mai 2019.
Donc, pour rappel, aujourd'hui, dans les sondages d'opinion, le Vlaams Belang est devenu le premier parti dans les sondages aujourd'hui, en novembre 2020...
Je disais d'abord qu'il faut toujours faire attention avec les sondages.
Tout à fait. Tout à fait. C'est pour ça que je précise bien que ce sont des sondages.
Les sondages créent plutôt des réalités politiques au lieu de les refléter.
D'accord. Oui.
Donc il faut toujours quand même faire attention. D'ailleurs,
d'abord parce que la méthodologie de beaucoup de sondages faits par Internet est assez problématique, mais aussi parce que parfois, bon, il y a un parti qui augmente de 3 % ou qui perd 3 %.
Et alors c'est complètement dans la marge d'erreur du sondage. Mais alors le journaliste, bon, qui doit quand même écrire cinq pages sur le sondage parce que ça a coûté beaucoup d'argent au journal,
va faire toute une histoire sur : « Le parti perd 3 % donc c'est la fin du socialisme en Flandre »-
Sans rester prudent.
La fin de, je ne sais pas, de l'écologie, etc. Bon, il faut quand même faire très attention toujours avec les sondages.
Bien sûr, bien sûr.
Mais je suis d'accord avec vous que bien sûr, le Vlaams Belang a le vent en poupe, ça, c'est clair.
C'est ça, oui, c'est ça. Donc il était déjà en très bonne position dans les urnes en mai 2019. Et voilà, la longue période de négociation a forcément tendance à favoriser les partis antisystème comme le Vlaams Belang ou le PTB.
Donc si on regarde spécifiquement le résultat en Flandre en 2019 aux élections fédérales, un grand vote nationaliste, un grand vote même à l'extrême droite, pour le Vlaams Belang.
Vous expliquiez dans une chronique pour De Standaard il y a peu : « En Flandre,
la parole fédéraliste se libère ». Vous disiez : « La jeune génération regarde la question des transferts de compétences de manière rationnelle, dans une logique d'efficacité
et plus vraiment sous le prisme du nationalisme flamand ».
« Les partis », vous disiez, « se rendent compte que l'opinion publique est de plus en plus favorable à la refédéralisation ».
Mais justement, quand on regarde le résultat des élections en Flandre, c'est très très brun, couleur du Vlaams Belang, c'est très très jaune, couleur de la N-VA.
Et ce sont justement, d'après ce qu'on a dit, d'après ce qu'on a pu lire, beaucoup de jeunes qui ont voté pour le Vlaams Belang, en particulier, on en reparlera, mais suite à,
voilà, aux grandes campagnes publicitaires qu'ils ont pu faire sur les réseaux sociaux.
Alors, est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'en Flandre, il y a deux jeunesses ? Cette jeunesse qui est moins,
voilà, focalisée sur le prisme du nationalisme flamand que vous décriviez dans cette chronique, et une autre jeunesse qui, justement, est très très très attachée à ce côté très flaminguant, très nationaliste, très,
très attachée à, voilà, cet, bah cet État-nation, justement, État-nation flamand.
Il y a beaucoup de choses à dire. Oui, je crois qu'on peut dire qu'en tout cas, la Flandre en général est assez divisée, parce que parfois, dans les médias francophones,
on m'invite un petit peu pour expliquer, voilà, ce que pense la Flandre.
C'est une question qu'on m'a posée souvent : « Monsieur Sinardet, que pense la Flandre ? » sur telle ou telle question.
Comme si j'étais un ambassadeur ou je ne sais pas quoi.
Ouais.
Donc généralement, ma réponse est de dire : « Si vous voulez savoir ça, il faut inviter la Flandre ». Moi, je peux vous dire ce que je pense comme politologue, certes flamand.
Et généralement, la réponse est : la Flandre est divisée, tout comme les francophones ne pensent pas tous la même chose non plus.
Enfin, j'espère pour eux. Voilà, et comme presque tous les pays européens sont assez divisés.
Un des pays les plus divisés sont d'ailleurs les États-Unis.
Tout à fait, tout à fait. Mais non, ce que je veux dire, c'est que quand on voit, voilà, ces observations, en particulier, je pense à des mouvements flaminguants comme Schild & Vrienden, je pense à, voilà,
des personnalités comme Dries Van Langenhove, et cetera.
Donc voilà, on voit un mouvement qui a de l'importance, qui fait parler de lui dans les médias, qui est concret et qui-- et c'est reflété dans les votes, dans les urnes.
Et en même temps, voilà, on vous lit et vous décrivez une parole de plus en plus pro refédéralisation, et cetera. Donc, on se dit : « Ah, deux mouvements qui prennent chacun de l'ampleur, qui ont de l'importance, mais qui sont vraiment incompatibles ».
Oui, mais bon, il faut aussi distinguer, bien sûr, la question communautaire, la question de la réforme de l'État, d'autres questions qui motivent probablement beaucoup plus le vote pour des partis comme le Vlaams Belang.
D'ailleurs, 'fin, les études le montrent depuis déjà très longtemps, les raisons pour lesquelles on vote pour le Vlaams Belang, c'est surtout les thèmes de l'immigration, de la diversité et de la sécurité.
D'ailleurs, comme dans beaucoup d'autres pays européens, ça, c'est quelque chose qui me frappe toujours quand je parle avec des journalistes ou d'autres personnes francophones.
Ils regardent ce qui se passe en Flandre et alors ils se disent : « Mais comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer qu'il y a tant de gens qui votent pour un parti d'extrême droite ou un parti de droite radicale ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe en Flandre ? Qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans l'eau de robinet des Flamands ? Mais comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer ça ?
» Tandis que, en fait, ce qu'il faut expliquer, c'est plutôt pourquoi un tel mouvement n'existe pas en Belgique francophone.
Parce que dans la plupart des pays et des régions européennes, il y a de tels mouvements d'extrême droite ou de droite radicale, en France, déjà depuis les années 80,
aux Pays-Bas, même en Allemagne, où historiquement, c'était quand même assez difficile.
On a vu aussi l'Alternative für Deutschland monter ces dernières années. Bon, en Autriche, enfin, bon, je peux encore en parler pendant 15 minutes.
Donc, l'exception européenne, plus ou moins, il y en a encore quelques autres, mais une des exceptions européennes, c'est plutôt, 'fin, là, c'est plutôt la Belgique francophone, ce n'est pas la Flandre.
Ce qu'on voit en Flandre, c'est simplement, voilà, ce qu'on voit dans beaucoup d'autres parties de l'Europe et du monde, c'est que des partis se forment sur un nouveau clivage, finalement, qui est le clivage
lié à la diversité, à l'immigration, où d'un côté, vous avez, voilà, des gens plus orientés vers la diversité, la multiculturalité, qui trouvent ça une bonne chose.
Et de l'autre côté, voilà, des gens qui résistent à ces évolutions.
J'ai envie de vous poser la question que vous proposiez : pourquoi cette exception, alors, en Belgique francophone ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas l'équivalent du Vlaams Belang ? Certains ont essayé avec le Parti populaire qui— d'ailleurs, on en avait parlé avec Frédéric Chardon il y a un an et demi.
Le Parti populaire et le Vlaams Belang ne s'aimaient pas du tout. Il y avait un conflit entre les deux partis tellement ils n'étaient pas alignés.
Mais donc oui, comment expliquer alors cette exception que représente la Belgique francophone ?
C'est une question très, très intéressante et très pertinente. Bon, je crois pas qu'il y a une réponse, mais en tout cas, je peux vous dire qu'elle n'est pas la raison.
Et ça, peut-être aussi, c'est important de dire dans un podcast francophone, parce que parfois, on dit : « Oui, mais voilà, les Flamands sont plus racistes ».
Où ils sont au moins plus ethnocentristes, ou ils sont moins fans d'immigration, de diversité, etc., que les francophones.
Toutes les études qu'on a là-dessus montrent que ça, ce n'est pas la raison, que c'est pas la bonne analyse, parce qu'on voit que, en fait, les francophones sont tout aussi ethnocentristes que les Flamands.
L'étude la plus récente de 2019, qui a en fait proposé, enfin demandé l'opinion d'un échantillon représentatif de Flamands et de Wallons sur un tas de thématiques liées à la politique fédérale,
a à nouveau montré que, bon, généralement d'ailleurs, les différences entre Flamands et Wallons étaient très limitées sur presque tous les terrains, mais notamment aussi, et ça, c'est très surprenant,
sur tout ce qui est lié à l'immigration, la diversité.
On voit qu'il y a en fait aussi chez les francophones un certain public, en tout cas, pour un parti comme la N-VA, voire le Vlaams Belang.
Les francophones sont sur ce point-là pas différents des autres.
Theo Francken score d'habitude assez assez haut dans les sondages de personnalités préférées des Belges francophones.
Absolument. On a vu, au moment où Jan Jambon et Francken étaient au gouvernement fédéral, qu'ils avaient des meilleurs scores de popularité que certains socialistes,
les plus visibles du Parti socialiste, par exemple, et que d'autres personnalités.
Donc, effectivement. Mais donc voilà. Donc je crois pas qu'il y a un problème avec la demande chez les électeurs francophones pour un tel parti, quoi que cette demande existe.
Peut-être qu'elle est un peu moins forte que du côté flamand, pas nécessairement en termes d'opinion, mais en termes de priorités.
Donc, par exemple, l'électeur francophone, quand il va voter, bon, il a peut-être plus ou moins la même vision sur la diversité que les Flamands, mais trouve peut-être ce thème-là un peu moins important.
Ça, c'est aussi ce qu'on voit parfois dans les études. Mais surtout, il y a pas d'offre du côté francophone. Il y a pas une offre crédible comme elle existe en Flandre.
Il y a effectivement une situation particulière en Belgique francophone, c'est que le MR occupe à la fois le centre droit, la droite traditionnelle un petit peu catholique.
Et puis, voilà, 'fin même tout le spectre, à droite de l'échiquier, à droite du spectre politique est grosso modo occupé par le MR.
Et alors, diverses personnalités qui peuvent occuper différentes places. Je me souviens que, par exemple, Denis Ducarme se présentait comme le Francken wallon, etc.
Donc voilà. Et inversement, une personnalité comme Christine Defraigne, voilà, incarnait beaucoup plus un côté féministe, progressiste, etc.
Donc il y a vraiment un large spectre de personnalités politiques au sein du MR.
En même temps, il y a aussi les gens qui pourraient voter pour un parti comme la N-VA ou le Vlaams Belang en Belgique francophone, aujourd'hui, sont pas nécessairement chez le MR.
Une partie importante de ces électeurs-là sont-- si c'est des partis de gauche, c'est le PS, c'est le PTB.
Parce que ça aussi, c'est quelque chose qu'on a vu dans beaucoup de pays européens, que les électeurs attirés par des partis de droite radicale ou d'extrême droite
viennent parfois des couches les plus populaires, sont souvent des gens un peu moins éduqués, avec un salaire plus bas, qui votaient historiquement plutôt pour des partis socialistes, sociaux-démocrates.
D'ailleurs, en Flandre, le Vlaams Belang, notamment ici à Anvers, 'fin, je connais très bien la situation politique, notamment à Anvers,
le Vlaams Blok, qui est d'abord monté bien sûr ici dans cette ville, a pris beaucoup d'électeurs du SP, parce que ce sont des électeurs qui sont
souvent assez à gauche sur l'axe socioéconomique, mais plutôt à droite sur l'axe, disons, socioculturel.
Identitaire, culturel, l'immigration.
Voilà, c'est ça. Et pour ces électeurs-là, en Belgique francophone, en fait, il y a pas de parti. Et ces électeurs-là sont aujourd'hui toujours fortement attirés par le PS et le PTB.
Et là, il y a peut-être aussi une autre explication du manque de succès de la droite radicale en Belgique francophone, c'est que le PS, au moins dans son discours et dans son profil, est resté plus un parti socialiste traditionnel
que beaucoup d'autres partis socialistes en Europe et notamment en Flandre, qui sont plutôt allés vers la troisième voie, hein, Blair, Schröder, etc.
Vandenbroucke un peu en Flandre. Et donc le PS a mieux réussi à garder cet électorat ouvrier, peu éduqué, bas salaire, traditionnel avec lui.
Électorat qui, en partie, est parti vers la droite dans d'autres régions et d'autres pays.
Donc ça, c'est aussi-- et c'est parce que c'est le profil du PS. C'est aussi, je crois, ce que le PS appelle la politique de proximité, hein.
Ils sont toujours assez fortement présents sur le terrain. Bon, certains appelleraient ça peut-être plutôt du clientélisme.
Ça dépend un petit peu comment on regarde la situation. Mais bon, le fait est que, voilà, le PS occupe quand même largement le terrain et le PTB a repris une partie de ces électeurs-là,
qu'aurait pu reprendre aussi un parti de droite radicale, je crois.
Donc le PS et aussi le PTB gardent un certain contrôle sur cet électorat populaire, ouvrier, etc. qui pourrait éventuellement être séduit par un parti, voilà, plutôt extrême droite, plutôt identitaire, plutôt nationaliste.
Mais comme le PS et le PTB sont présents et ont un vrai contrôle, ont une mainmise sur cet électorat-là, ça n'a pas vraiment l'occasion d'arriver, si je comprends bien.
Oui, c'est une partie de l'explication, en tout cas.
OK.
Aussi parce que, voilà, l'offre du côté de la droite radicale n'est pas très forte. Je crois que s'il y aurait vraiment un personnage charismatique, intelligent, communicatif, du côté francophone,
je crois que ça pourrait marcher aussi, hein, mais bon, 'fin les...
Rien n'est impossible.
Oui, mais ce qu'on a vu, voilà.
Oui, c'est ça. Vous pensez spécifiquement à...
Aux figures d'antan des Front national, des gens comme Daniel Féret, par exemple, ou plus récemment à Mischaël Modrikamen.
Oui, oui.
Donc qui est aussi une figure quand même un peu trop bourgeois pour vraiment-
Il est millionnaire, etc.
Oui, c'est ça. Bon, 'fin, Trump a aussi réussi à attirer des gens modestes, mais quand même.
Vous présentez vraiment la chose en expliquant que
dans le paysage médiatique francophone, on a souvent tendance à présenter la Flandre comme avec un potentiel raciste, un potentiel identitaire, etc., plus important qu'en Belgique francophone.
Et c'est intéressant puisque effectivement, moi, en tant que Belge francophone, dans les médias, j'entends souvent parler de ces interventions Pukkelpop ou des groupes de
racistes flamands vont chanter des chansons comme De Kangoeroes vannens, etc.
On entend parler de scandales à la KUL où des étudiants meurent lors de baptêmes estudiantins et se font appeler de manière raciste, etc.
On a effectivement des figures comme Theo Francken-
En même temps, je me rappelle du côté francophone de cette présentatrice météo, je crois—
Tout à fait, oui.
...d'origine africaine qui se faisait totalement insulter avec des propos racistes sur les médias sociaux par des francophones.
Donc ça, ça a quand même fait aussi
beaucoup de bruit et à juste titre, hein. Mais je veux dire, donc à nouveau, je crois pas que les Flamands ont le monopole sur les incidents racistes qui sont absolument à rejeter, bien sûr, qu'ils soient francophones ou flamands.
OK. Donc c'est-
En même temps, en même temps, je-- pour aller un peu dans votre direction, ce qui existe bien sûr plus fortement en Flandre, c'est des mouvements nationalistes.
Bon, pour ça, il y a des raisons historiques liées aussi à l'extrême droite et la droite radicale. Donc ça, il y a ce terreau historique, mais à nouveau, là, une nuance, hein, parce que quand on regarde, quand on
revient, par exemple, dans la fin des années 70, début des années 80, là, il y avait aussi des mouvances d'extrême droite qui étaient surtout francophones, hein. Et d'ailleurs,
dans les années 80, il y avait aussi des figures, notamment au PRL,
je pense à Nols, à Schaerbeek, par exemple, mais aussi d'autres
qui avaient des propos qui, à ce moment-là, n'étaient pas vraiment présents très fortement dans le débat politique flamand, parce que c'était avant le succès du Vlaams Blok, hein.
Je rappelle par exemple que Nols, comme bourgmestre de Schaerbeek, à un certain moment, il s'est mis sur un chameau avec une djellaba pour aller vers sa maison communale.
Et c'était donc un statement contre le droit de vote pour les immigrés. Bon, je crois que Filip Dewinter, à ce moment-là, qui n'était pas encore une figure très populaire, ça l'aurait presque fait rougir, pour ainsi dire, hein.
Donc c'est typiquement le genre d'action que-
Ouais, c'est ça.
...que ferait un Filip Dewinter dans le-
OK.
Donc voilà. Donc à nouveau, il y a quand même
je crois pas, 'fin sur ce plan-là, je crois pas que la Flandre et la Belgique francophone soient aussi différentes que ça, mais sont pas différentes non plus des tendances dans toute l'Europe.
Dans d'autres pays européens, oui. Il faut remettre les choses en perspective. Et ouais, je suis assez d'accord avec ça.
Comparer aussi avec les autres pays européens, pas juste
entre les différentes régions en Belgique. Un point quand même sur lequel j'aimerais m'attarder, c'est : voilà, il n'y a pas d'équivalent au mouvement Schild & Vrienden, par exemple, en Belgique francophone.
On n'a pas un élu comme
Dries Van Langenhove à la Chambre des représentants du côté francophone.
L'explication qu'on nous présente typiquement dans les médias francophones, c'est voilà : la bourgeoisie francophone, historiquement en Belgique, a très fort tenté d'écraser
l'identité flamande, le fait d'être néerlandophone, de parler néerlandais, et qui donc amène,
voilà, en réponse, un mouvement de protestation, un mouvement radical, un mouvement nationaliste, une identité qui,
qui n'a pas envie de se laisser faire.
Voilà, les Flamings, tout simplement. Et donc, in fine,
on en arrive, voilà, fin des années 2010, à des mouvements, des réseaux, des groupes sur les réseaux sociaux type Schild & Vrienden qui sont vraiment très très flamings, très anti-francophones, très anti-immigration, très voilà.
Parce que vraiment, il y a ce côté : la Flandre est ta nation, on est un peuple, une couleur de peau, une langue, le néerlandais, une terre.
Et d'ailleurs, voilà, c'est aussi quelque chose qu'on a pu voir avec BHV, c'est : on essaye d'amener l'identité francophone dans la périphérie bruxelloise et surtout pas la terre flamande.
C'est la terre flamande, on y parle le néerlandais, on reste flamand en Flandre. Là, il y a quand même une différence nette entre la Flandre et la Belgique francophone à ce niveau-là.
Bon, l'exemple BHV est bien sûr aussi lié à la logique de territorialité linguistique en Belgique. Et là, j'ai eu des discussions intéressantes dans le passé, notamment avec Olivier Maingain, sur la question.
Je trouvais très bizarre que Olivier Maingain, parce qu'il était président-
Président de la Fédération des francophones, hein.
Oui, oui, du FDF. Mais il était aussi président de la Ligue des peuples francophones. Et dans ce rôle-là, il représentait aussi notamment les Québécois, hein.
Voilà, donc les nationalistes et séparatistes québécois, hein, parce que c'était notamment eux qui étaient dans cette organisation.
Donc Maingain, comme président du FDF, disait en fait : « Oui, effectivement, bon, un peu ce que vous dites, hein,
oui, les Flamands sont pas démocratiques », parce que, par exemple, dans les communes à facilité, il y a 90 % de francophones et quand même, on veut que ça reste flamand.
On veut scinder BHV, on veut enlever un droit aux francophones de voter pour des francophones, etc.
Donc, en Belgique, il dit vraiment que la logique de territorialité linguistique, c'est antidémocratique, c'est mauvais, etc.
Pourtant, c'est exactement la même logique défendue par les francophones au Canada,
les nationalistes québécois qui ont toujours aussi défendu ce principe : le Québec doit être francophone pour protéger, voilà, les francophones contre la dominance de l'anglais, tout comme les Flamands ont dit : « Voilà, la Flandre
doit être néerlandophone pour
protéger de la dominance du français », hein, parce qu'historiquement
effectivement, le français était la langue la plus forte, tout comme l'anglais au Canada, même si en Belgique, les Flamands sont majoritaires et au Canada, les francophones sont minoritaires, mais la,
la langue la plus forte qui domine plus facilement la langue la plus faible,
là, ce que le néerlandais est en Belgique, le français l'est au Canada.
Et donc intellectuellement, j'avais un problème-- enfin, je comprenais pas très bien comment Maingain pouvait dire que ce principe de territorialité était antidémocratique en Belgique, mais le défendait finalement,
dans sa logique de défense des Québécois au Canada.
Donc à nouveau, associer la défense du système de territorialité linguistique à une sorte de
sentiment anti-francophone, voire raciste, me semble pas complètement correct dans le sens où, voilà, c'est ce que font aussi des francophones ailleurs quand ils sont confrontés à une situation similaire.
On peut effectivement-- j'dirais qu'on peut effectivement comparer la Flandre et la situation au Québec dans le sens où il y a ce côté langue dominante.
Au Canada, ce serait plutôt l'anglais, ici, ce serait plutôt le français, dont on a envie de se protéger pour conserver une identité, une indépendance.
Voilà, ne pas voir sa langue, son héritage, sa culture disparaître, se faire écraser par la langue dominante.
Donc ça, on peut comparer. Ce que je dirais, c'est justement cet aspect-là qui fait que ça peut facilement se transformer en xénophobie.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ? En,
en, voilà, en champ raciste, en Schild & Vrienden, etc. Je fais le lien entre cet aspect : je protège mon identité, je protège ma terre, je protège ma culture, et voilà, les groupes Facebook type Schild & Vrienden.
Oui, oui, c'est ça. C'est pas-- le lien n'est pas nécessairement là, hein. On voit aussi qu'il y a des nationalismes plutôt de gauche et progressistes.
Pourtant, Schild & Vrienden n'a pas vraiment d'équivalent côté francophone. Parce qu'on n'est justement pas trop dans cette logique, voilà, identitaire.
Oui, en même temps, Schild & Vrienden, c'est assez comparable à certains groupes en France, hein, donc Génération Identitaire.
C'est ça, voilà, ce genre de choses, ouais.
Ouais, c'est ça. Donc, en fait, Schild & Vrienden, bon, là aussi, on pourrait s'y attarder encore longtemps.
C'est d'un côté, ça s'est bâti sur une tradition qui existe dans le mouvement flamand, historiquement, une tradition plutôt d'extrême droite, droite radicale.
Donc dans ce sens, on pourrait dire que Schild & Vrienden est un peu l'héritier du VMO, par exemple, du Vlaamse Militanten Orde.
Il y a cette-- voilà, il y a une continuité historique sur ce plan-là.
En même temps, Schild & Vrienden est aussi un phénomène qu'on peut voir comme l'équivalent flamand de ce qu'on voit dans beaucoup d'autres pays, à nouveau, aussi aux États-Unis, donc des mouvements,
souvent aussi, surtout online, etc.,
racistes et autres, identitaires.
Donc c'est un peu les-- on pourrait dire que c'est un peu les deux. Les deux se rejoignent un petit peu dans ce mouvement-là.
En même temps, il faut aussi faire attention à ne pas, voilà, faire l'équivalent entre ces mouvements-là et la Flandre en général.
Et il faut aussi faire une distinction entre des motivations sur la question de l'immigration, de la diversité, de la sécurité, pour voter pour un parti, et des motivations nationalistes, dans le sens d'indépendance, séparatisme, etc.
Donc là, il est quand même important de rappeler que le séparatisme en Flandre, hein, comme vraiment une position défendue par l'opinion publique, est extrêmement minoritaire, hein. Donc c'est entre
5 et 10 % sur base des études les plus récentes. D'ailleurs, la N-VA, qui officiellement est un parti séparatiste quand on lit ses statuts,
ne parle plus jamais de Flandre indépendante ou de séparatisme, déjà depuis très longtemps, parce que, voilà, ils savent très bien que ça peut effrayer des électeurs plutôt que de les attirer.
Même le Vlaams Belang, qui est clairement séparatiste, ne fait pas campagne sur ces thèmes-là, hein, quand on analyse la propagande du Vlaams Belang 2019.
Oui, propagande, mais bon, je pourrais aussi parler de la propagande du PTB, du PS ou même voire du CD&V.
D'accord, OK. Donc c'est un terme que vous employez facilement.
Oui, c'est un terme qu'on peut employer, mais c'est vrai qu'il-- 'fin, qui peut sembler un peu péjoratif. En communication politique, ça peut être utilisé pour chaque parti, euh...
Ouais, ouais. Mais donc, voilà, donc même le Vlaams Belang ne va pas faire campagne là-dessus.
Plutôt sur les thèmes sociaux, sur la détresse sociale, etc.
Oui, oui, c'est ça.
Et l'immigration que sur la scission de la Belgique, ouais.
D'ailleurs, des gens comme-- 'fin, il y a beaucoup de nationalistes flamands, en fait, qui se plaignent de la situation en Flandre.
Je me rappelle Geert Bourgeois, quand il était encore ministre-président flamand, à un certain moment, à la radio, à la VRT, c'était le moment où il y avait, voilà, toute la—
toutes les dynamiques en Catalogne autour du référendum, etc.
À un certain moment, il s'est vraiment plaint que les Flamands n'étaient pas un peu plus comme les Catalans. Parce que les Catalans, au moins,
ils allaient dans la rue pour revendiquer leur identité catalane, le monde culturel, le monde syndical, le monde des médias, tous sont fortement derrière cette identité catalane et ce nationalisme catalan.
Et en Flandre, c'est pas du tout le cas. Là, on rejette l'identité flamande, on n'est pas patriote, on n'est pas nationaliste.
C'est pas moi qui le dis, c'est Geert Bourgeois qui le dit. Bart De Wever, dans son dernier livre sur l'identité, à un certain moment, écrit aussi : « Il y a un très grand attachement,
tant chez les Flamands, les Wallons que les Bruxellois,
à la nation belge ».
Clairement, il le déplore, mais il dit : « Voilà, c'est malheureusement la réalité avec laquelle nous devons travailler ».
Donc, je constate que des nationalistes flamands disent que la Flandre est moins nationaliste, en tout cas dans, 'fin, dans certaines interviews, que certains francophones.
Oui, c'est ça. C'est intéressant. Clairement, voilà, si on regarde la situation de la Catalogne
Peuple, on peut parler d'un système d'oppression, de, voilà, de liberté qui leur sont, enfin qui sont revendiquées et qui ne leur sont pas accordées.
On peut difficilement faire le parallèle avec la Flandre, il me semble, même si voilà, peut-être que-
En tout cas pas avec la Flandre d'aujourd'hui.
Oui, c'est ça. Voilà, voilà, c'est ça. Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est de voir qu'effectivement des personnalités comme Geert Bourgeois-
On peut aussi faire la comparaison avec l'Écosse, par exemple, qui l'a-- bon, on peut pas dire non plus que, voilà, qu'elle est discriminée ou enfin que les Écossais sont vraiment discriminés.
Mais là aussi, on voit quand même que le soutien, par exemple, pour l'indépendance écossaise tourne quand même autour des 50 %, hein.
D'ailleurs, aujourd'hui, il est plus haut que jamais, aussi dû en partie à la crise corona, mais bon.
Effectivement, le parallèle est intéressant. Des personnalités comme Geert Bourgeois, dans leur esprit, ce sentiment d'oppression, il est toujours un peu là et « Ah, il faudrait que les Flamands s'en rendent un peu plus compte », etc.
Donc, il parle, Bart De Wever et Geert Bourgeois parlent de cette identité belge qui est forte et qui est très présente en Belgique, que ce soit au Nord ou au Sud du pays.
Effectivement, en Belgique francophone, on a surtout l'habitude de dépeindre la Flandre comme, voilà, Vlaamse leeuw et les drapeaux avec le lion, etc.
Et les grands rassemblements pour la fête de la Flandre en été. Donc oui, là y a vraiment un grand écart entre les deux descriptions.
Oui, quand même, oui, oui. Je crois que
sur ce point-là, il y a quand même certains malentendus. J'ai notamment aussi déjà fait, enfin contribué à beaucoup d'études sur le sentiment d'appartenance, sur les identités des Flamands, des Wallons, enfin en Belgique.
Et là aussi, on voit, systématiquement, hein, donc on a vraiment des chiffres pour les trois dernières décennies.
Bon d'abord, on voit que pour beaucoup de Flamands, l'identité belge et l'identité flamande ne sont pas des identités opposées.
Donc beaucoup de Flamands disent : « Je me sens et flamand et belge ». C'est la grande majorité. Mais quand on demande vraiment aux Flamands : « Bon, dites-nous maintenant ce que vous vous sentez en premier »,
c'est toujours l'identité belge qui revient pour la grande majorité et plus de 50 %.
Mais alors souvent, ceux-là disent : « Mais en deuxième lieu, je me sens flamand ».
Oui.
Et inversement, l'identité flamande revient en premier que pour-
Une minorité
...oui, 20, 25 % des Flamands généralement. Et souvent, pour ceux-là, l'identité belge est la deuxième. En fait, y a que, dans tous les chiffres qu'on a,
y a que à peu près 10 % au maximum qui disent : « Je me sens seulement flamand et je rejette complètement l'identité belge ».
Donc ça, c'est vraiment les 10 %, c'est vraiment le kern de nationalistes convaincus.
Y a peut-être alors un focus dans les médias francophones sur ces 25 %, sur ces 10 % et on a tendance à vraiment peut-être grossir au microscope, ce qui est finalement un phénomène assez minoritaire. Vous voudriez ça ?
Oui, en ce qui concerne vraiment le nationalisme flamand anti-belge, oui, effectivement, c'est clairement une minorité.
Ça explique aussi, par exemple, pourquoi, hein, si à nouveau, on fait la comparaison avec d'autres partis nationalistes en Europe,
les partis nationalistes flamands sont les seuls à ne pas revendiquer un référendum sur la scission du pays et sur l'indépendance de la Flandre.
Hein, en Écosse, on a revendiqué et fait un référendum. Maintenant, on commence à nouveau, déjà cinq années plus tard, à en vouloir un nouveau.
En Catalogne, bon, les nationalistes revendiquent un référendum depuis très longtemps. Ils ont même organisé des référendums illégaux parce qu'ils pouvaient pas avoir un référendum légal.
Au Québec, il y a eu deux référendums en 80, en 95. Partout, les nationalistes demandent des référendums, sauf en Flandre, parce qu'ils savent que y a très peu de chances qu'ils gagneraient un tel référendum.
Ouais.
C'est aussi lié, bien sûr, à une autre différence, c'est que la plupart des autres régions et des mouvements nationalistes que j'ai nommés, ils représentent des minorités dans un pays, hein.
Bien sûr, les Flamands sont la majorité-
Oui, oui
...en Belgique. Donc c'est probablement aussi pour ça que y a moins cette volonté de scission que peut-être dans d'autres régions où on est vraiment la minorité.
Voilà, moins ce sentiment d'oppression, ce sentiment d'être écrasé par une majorité, puisque les Flamands sont la majorité.
Je crois qu'effectivement, y a plus vraiment beaucoup de Flamands qui se sentent vraiment totalement opprimés,
parce que voilà, ils vivent aussi finalement dans, enfin dans une logique, dans un milieu néerlandophone assez décomplexé.
Prenons un exemple intéressant que j'avais d'ailleurs cité quand j'interviewais François Gemenne il y a quelques semaines, quelques mois.
Au moment de la crise du coronavirus qu'on connaît encore aujourd'hui, mais qui-- donc c'était déjà, je crois que c'était au printemps dernier,
je dirais avril, mai, quelque part par là, où on se posait la question de : « Alors les écoles, est-ce qu'on les garde ouvertes ?
Est-ce qu'on les ferme ? Est-ce qu'on donne cours ? Est-ce qu'on fait des cours à distance ? Comment est-ce qu'on fait ?
» Et il y avait une campagne de la N-VA, donc des posters, des tracts, des flyers, etc.,
qui disait : « Nous, l'école, on veut bien que les élèves continuent à y aller, même si c'est l'été, parce que voilà, il faut travailler dur, etc.
» Et en faisant la comparaison avec la situation en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles où c'était : « Non, non, l'été, les écoles sont fermées, c'est comme ça, c'est inévitable ».
Et donc vraiment cette comparaison de « Nous, on est mieux. Nous, on travaille, on ne va pas se laisser affaiblir par-- enfin juste parce que c'est les vacances.
Voilà, on va juste faire ce qu'il faut. Voilà, c'est comme ça ». Et certains en Belgique, je pense spécifiquement à Alain Gerlache, avaient commenté ça en disant
: « Le nationalisme, ça reste au final un complexe d'infériorité, de tout le temps se faire une comparaison, de dire : Regardez, nous, on est meilleurs.
Regardez, regardez, regardez ». Est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette analyse que c'est un complexe d'infériorité non résolu ?
C'est très psychanalytique, hein, donc je sais pas si on peut-
Je suis assez d'accord, oui,
Bon, dans chaque nationalisme, il faut-- parce que souvent, on dit le nationalisme, c'est surtout, bon, l'amour de la propre nation, du propre peuple ou de la propre région, propre pays, et cetera.
Mais, paradoxalement, on a toujours, pour chaque nationalisme, on a aussi besoin d'un autre.
La Flandre, l'identité flamande n'existerait pas sans une autre identité, une autre nationalité, contre laquelle on peut se profiler et avec laquelle on peut se comparer.
Et donc, le nationalisme flamand a besoin de la Wallonie, notamment, hein, pour, voilà, pour se profiler. Et donc le fait de dire : « Bon, les Wallons, effectivement, sont peut-être un peu plus fainéants, moins... » Ouais, voilà.
Ça permet en même temps de dire : « Voilà, nous,
nous, les Flamands, nous, on est travailleurs et on est--
» Mais même chose pour le régionalisme ou finalement le nationalisme wallon, parce qu'on dit toujours qu'il y a jamais eu de nationalisme wallon, mais-- bon, ça nous mènerait peut-être un peu trop loin, mais y
a-- en fait, y a des, ben des figures politiques intellectuelles importantes qu'on pourrait très bien appeler nationalistes pour une raison ou une autre.
On les appelle régionalistes, mais qui disent aussi : « Voilà, la Wallonie est-- il y a une identité wallonne, il y a un peuple wallon et donc la Wallonie devrait avoir plus d'autonomie pour cette raison-là.
» Bon, ça, c'est du nationalisme.
OK.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est que les nationalistes wallons ne veulent pas s'appeler nationalistes parce que le nationalisme, c'est mauvais.
Et surtout, le nationalisme, c'est flamand. Parce que, hein, les Flamands, c'est nationaliste, c'est à droite, c'est raciste, et cetera.
Et les Wallons, par contre, sont tout au plus régionalistes, pas nationalistes, pas racistes, ouverts, progressistes, accueillants.
Donc là, à nouveau, une certaine identité wallonne que certains ont essayé de bâtir, c'est aussi bâti contre une certaine perception de l'identité flamande.
Ce chauvinisme qu'on associe souvent à la Flandre, cette xénophobie, ce fait d'être recentré sur soi-même, et cetera,
ces caractéristiques qu'on associe à la Flandre, en fait, sont aussi présentes en Wallonie.
Est-ce que vous diriez que-
Oui, mais en même temps, ces caractéristiques sont utilisées pour bâtir une image du Wallon à l'opposé.
C'est ça.
Tout comme l'image du Wallon fainéant est utilisée pour bâtir une image de l'identité flamande qui est opposée à cela. Ouais, ouais.
OK, OK. Un autre point qui a souvent été soulevé en ce qui concerne les élections fédérales de 2019, même les élections générales en 2019, que ce soit au niveau des régions ou au niveau fédéral,
c'est l'usage des réseaux sociaux par les partis politiques, en particulier le Vlaams Belang, la N-VA, le PTB, ont fait des dépenses très importantes sur les réseaux sociaux.
Donc, peut-être, on va en parler, mais peut-être pour atteindre un public plus populaire, qui regarde moins les médias traditionnels, la Première ou la VRT, et cetera.
Un projet de loi va bientôt être introduit en décembre. Je pense que c'est justement Gilles Vanden Burre, qu'on a reçu dans ce podcast il y a bientôt deux ans, qui va s'en occuper.
Donc une résolution pour encadrer, légiférer les dépenses que les partis politiques peuvent faire sur les réseaux sociaux.
Voilà, sans doute dans l'idée que ça va permettre de freiner l'essor de ces partis, en particulier le Vlaams Belang, qui, voilà, vont employer des
techniques populistes pour, voilà, présenter des contre-vérités, présenter-- s'inventer une nouvelle vérité et-
Des fake news.
Voilà, voilà, c'est ça. Ben d'ailleurs, dans les articles qu'on a pu lire au sujet de cette résolution, voilà, y avait,
Tom Van Grieken qui posait beaucoup de questions à Facebook autour de : « Oui, mais alors, est-ce qu'on peut payer des Facebook ads si l'info est mensongère, et cetera ?
Est-ce que voilà ? » Parce qu'il y a chez Facebook une politique où
on lutte très fort contre les fake news, mais si vous êtes un acteur politique, par exemple le président américain, alors, voilà, la vérité est un concept un peu plus laxiste.
On a un peu plus le droit de mentir. Bref, donc, je m'écarte un petit peu. Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette possibilité de légiférer à ce sujet ?
Est-ce que ça vous semble être judicieux pour lutter contre l'extrême droite en Belgique ?
Je devrais d'abord voir le projet ou la proposition de loi-
Elle est pas encore sortie, hein, ouais
...pour voir, voilà, ce que j'en pense exactement.
Mais sur le papier, de manière générale, le concept.
Bah, sortons peut-être tout ça d'abord un tout petit peu du débat de la lutte contre l'extrême droite. Bon, on a un système en Belgique où les dépenses de campagne sont très limitées, hein.
Y a des règles pour tout, hein. Donc, par exemple, on peut pas faire de spots télé pendant une période avant les élections.
L'argent qu'on dépense pour d'autres formes de publicité est aussi limité. En même temps, pour les médias sociaux et pour tout ce qui est online, y a presque pas de règles.
Donc là, bon,
là, y a un problème, bien sûr, hein, parce que c'est un peu bizarre de dire : « Oui, vous pouvez pas faire de spots télé, mais en même temps, ce que vous faites sur Facebook, Twitter, Instagram, voire TikTok,
là, on s'en fout complètement.
» Bon, c'est plus la réalité parce que les médias sociaux ont probablement un effet plus important qu'un spot télé.
Donc il est logique, dans le cadre de cette législation, de, voilà, de suivre l'évolution des moyens de communication et de la société, et donc de revoir tout cela.
Donc, dans ce sens-là, je comprends qu'il faut un débat là-dessus. En même temps, bien sûr,
cette évolution avec les médias sociaux crée aussi de nouveaux problèmes, hein, avec effectivement le problème des fake news.
Bon, là, je crois qu'il faut être très prudent parce que, voilà, c'est difficile de-- 'fin, il faut éviter, bien sûr, d'aller vers une sorte de ministère de la Propagande qui va décider ce qui est vrai et ce qui est faux.
D'ailleurs, je crois pas que ça pourrait marcher, mais bon, on sent aussi que ça crée quand même déjà un peu des problèmes.
Je crois que la seule bonne solution, c'est une sorte d'autorégulation de certains médias sociaux, hein.
On voyait par exemple Twitter, ces dernières semaines-
Oh, même plus que ces dernières semaines. Les publicités politiques sont maintenant interdites sur Twitter depuis-
Effectivement
...depuis quelques mois, ouais.
Mais ce que je voulais dire aussi, c'est que, par exemple, parce que vous citiez Trump, voilà, les tweets de Trump disant : « J'ai gagné l'élection et l'autre a perdu », ont été accompagnés,
de messages Twitter pour dire : « Voilà, cette information
est disputée. »
C'est faisable, je crois, pour, voilà, des personnalités-
Oui
...très importantes comme, voilà, Donald Trump. Je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit imaginable pour chaque élu du Vlaams Belang ou de la N-VA ou du PTB ou d'un autre parti.
Ça me semble plus difficile, même si, voilà, si on
Si les médias sociaux engagent des gens par pays qui connaissent très bien la situation dans le pays, bon, mais c'est vrai que chaque solution bute directement, et je suis assez d'accord avec vous, sur
des contraintes ou sur des problèmes.
Mais enfin, j'attends de voir quelle est la proposition concrète pour vraiment--
Mais c'est clair que les fake news, voilà, c'est quelque chose sur laquelle on-- il faut réfléchir, c'est quelque chose sur laquelle il faut peut-être essayer de prendre effectivement des initiatives.
En même temps, voilà, il y a aussi un certain danger de créer, voilà, des sortes de ministères de la propagande.
C'est clair que les médias sociaux permettent effectivement, peut-être de façon plus efficace et sournoise, d'atteindre certains buts.
Mais voilà, les affiches du Parti nazi de Hitler n'étaient pas moins problématiques dans les années 30 parce qu'Hitler n'était pas sur Facebook ou sur Instagram, je veux dire.
Donc c'est plutôt le-- enfin, c'est le type de message qui peut être problématique, pas nécessairement le moyen utilisé.
Je dirais que la technique de microciblage en elle-même est dangereuse pour la démocratie et le message peut l'être aussi.
Donc c'est pas forcément l'un ou l'autre, c'est, ça peut être les deux. Et en l'occurrence, pour le Vlaams Belang, c'est les deux.
Oui, oui, c'est ça. Mais à nouveau, le microciblage, est-ce que c'est totalement nouveau ? Bon, dans le passé, on allait aussi coller certaines affiches dans certains quartiers, peut-être avec beaucoup d'ouvriers,
et d'autres affiches complètement différentes du même parti dans un quartier riche.
Mais je comprends ce que vous voulez dire. C'est clair que voilà, oui.
C'est pas aussi puissant quoi, en termes d'échelle, en termes de précision, voilà.
Si je devais vous poser la question à un million, hein, si on prend Paris aujourd'hui, est-ce que ça pourrait avoir un effet concret sur le résultat des élections ?
À nouveau, tout dépend de ce qu'on veut faire exactement, parce que ça reste quand même très vague en ce moment. Par contre, il y a peut-être un risque que ça pourrait profiter justement au Vlaams Belang.
Si on prend une initiative qui peut être présentée par le Vlaams Belang comme justement une manière de faire taire le parti ou d'essayer de,
de faire du tort au parti, voilà, ils peuvent utiliser ça pour justement se renforcer.
Je repense au moment où le Vlaams Blok avait été condamné pour racisme. Bon, à ce moment-là, il a pu présenter cette décision, justement, comme une tentative de l'establishment politique belge de l'éliminer.
Et donc ça, justement, le meilleur score du Vlaams Belang, historiquement, c'était justement juste après la condamnation pour racisme lors des élections régionales de 2004.
Donc, il faut quand même aussi faire attention,
à ne pas prendre des initiatives qui pourraient justement être utilisées par des partis d'extrême droite pour démontrer que leur framing d'un establishment qui,
voilà, qui veut les éliminer de façon illégitime, qu'on renforce pas justement ce discours-là.
Ce gouvernement, qui donc est apparu il y a quelques semaines, le gouvernement De Croo, on l'appelle aussi le gouvernement Vivaldi.
Qu'est-ce que les Flamands, et encore une fois, que pense la Flandre
? Qu'est-ce que les Flamands, de manière générale, il y aura certainement plusieurs opinions que vous aurez à nous présenter, mais qu'est-ce que les Flamands pensent de ce nouveau gouvernement fédéral ?
Et je pense en particulier à ce hashtag qui a pris beaucoup de poids, qui est le fameux hashtag #nietmijnregering, principalement utilisé par les partis de l'opposition N-VA ou Vlaams Belang.
Le gouvernement Vivaldi, est-ce qu'il était bien reçu en Flandre ?
Je dirais à nouveau, la Flandre est divisée, c'est assez clair. Je crois que c'est un peu tôt, mais c'est clair que voilà, qu'une grande partie des Flamands, voire la moitié, va,
va être difficile à enthousiasmer pour ce gouvernement.
En même temps, ce qu'on a quand même vu dans le premier sondage, à nouveau, les sondages, je suis très très très sceptique.
Mais voilà, soudainement, je crois que c'était une ou deux semaines après la formation du gouvernement, Alexander De Croo et Frank Vandenbroucke étaient le numéro un et le numéro deux de popularité en Flandre.
Donc voilà, donc il y a aussi quand même, voilà, un certain soutien, mais un paradoxe parce que leur parti, et les SPA restaient à des scores très bas.
Alors, on ne peut pas se quitter sans aborder la lourde question qui a été centrale ces derniers mois en politique en Belgique, qui est évidemment
la crise du COVID-19, et la gestion qui en a été faite par les différents gouvernements, le gouvernement
temporaire de Sophie Wilmès et puis aujourd'hui celui de Alexander De Croo avec Frank Vandenbroucke. Vous avez dit : « Le fait qu'il
pleut des critiques justifiées sur les mesures divergentes par région et sur la cacophonie et la confusion chez les citoyens qu'elles engendrent montre qu'une logique fédérale n'est pas la bonne pour gérer une crise sanitaire en Belgique.
» Donc, vous êtes critique de cette approche fédérale pour gérer la crise du coronavirus ?
Pas complètement. Donc la logique fédérale, en fait, c'est d'avoir des mesures diversifiées par région. Ça, c'est la logique dans un État fédéral.
On a différentes régions, communautés ou autres entités fédérées qui, sur leurs compétences, prennent des décisions différentes.
Par exemple, quand on regarde l'Allemagne, pays fédéral, on a constaté, notamment pendant le premier lockdown, que dans différents États allemands, on avait des mesures différentes.
Et ça faisait que d'un côté du Donau, on pouvait se promener librement, de l'autre côté de la rivière, on devait faire que des déplacements essentiels.
D'un côté d'un parc, il fallait garder deux mètres de distance, de l'autre côté du parc, un mètre et demi.
D'un côté du pont, il y avait des magasins fermés, de l'autre côté du pont, les magasins de la même chaîne étaient ouverts parce que les Länder
décidaient eux-mêmes et parce que Merkel n'arrivait pas à les mettre sur la même ligne.
Donc ça, c'est une logique finalement fédérale, parce que voilà, les Länder ont-
Les entités fédérées ont une certaine autonomie
...les compétences, voilà, pour se décider différemment.
OK. Donc c'est la logique fédérale-
Donc ça, c'est la logique fédérale qu'on a vue en Allemagne, qu'on a vue notamment aussi en Grande-Bretagne, même si c'est un pays pas complètement fédéral, avec aussi des divergences énormes entre l'Écosse, le Pays de Galles et l'Angleterre.
On a vu ça aussi en Espagne d'ailleurs. Mais alors, ironiquement, en Belgique, on a vu en fait une approche pas du tout fédérale en fait.
On a vu une approche très nationale, presque unitaire, dans la prise de mesures en tout cas, hein.
En mars dernier, il y avait une certaine différence quand même entre des politiques francophones et néerlandophones sur les écoles.
Du côté flamand, on tendait plutôt quand même vers garder les écoles ouvertes. Du côté francophone, parce qu'on regarde toujours la France, on fait--
enfin, parfois, je me demande pourquoi est-ce qu'on a des responsables politiques francophones belges, parce que finalement, ils copient simplement ce qu'ils ont fait en France.
Mais bon, ça, c'est une parenthèse.
C'est un point de vue, ouais.
Mais donc, il y avait une différence nord-sud au niveau politique.
Et alors, ce qu'on fait normalement en Belgique, c'est simplement de dire : « Bon alors, les Flamands font leur truc et les francophones font leur truc.
» En plus, sur une compétence comme l'enseignement qui a déjà été complètement communautarisée. Mais non, on a dit : « Non, on peut pas faire ça.
On peut pas laisser les écoles flamandes ouvertes et les francophones fermées », notamment parce qu'à Bruxelles, voilà, il y aurait des écoles fermées et ouvertes en même temps.
En fait, toute l'élite politique belge a été d'accord pendant presque toute cette période de Corona, de toujours suivre une logique nationale dans les mesures appliquées.
C'est assez quand même surprenant, notamment quand on compare avec l'Allemagne, dont on a une image beaucoup plus homogène et beaucoup moins divisée, où là, il y avait vraiment des situations typiquement belges,
comme je viens d'en donner quelques-unes.
Et alors, il y a eu une exception à cette règle nationale. On a quand même expérimenté avec cette logique fédérale fin octobre,
où là, il y avait un comité de concertation où il y avait plus de consensus, où notamment Jambon, pour le gouvernement flamand, a dit : « Nous, on veut pas aller trop loin dans des mesures restrictives.
» Donc, le comité de concertation a annoncé pour toute la Belgique certaines mesures. Mais ensuite, le gouvernement wallon a annoncé des mesures additionnelles.
Le jour d'après, le gouvernement bruxellois a aussi annoncé des mesures additionnelles encore un peu différentes que celles en Wallonie.
Par exemple, à Bruxelles, on fermait tous les théâtres et pas en Wallonie à ce moment-là.
Et alors, quatre jours après, le gouvernement flamand s'est quand même vu sous la pression des virologues et autres, s'est quand même vu contraint de prendre aussi les mêmes mesures.
Après quoi, on a tout réajusté et rendu les mesures à nouveau homogènes pour tout le territoire, sauf le couvre-feu.
Sur ce coup, Jan Jambon a un peu perdu la face sur ce coup-là.
Oui, Jambon a complètement perdu la face parce que le vendredi encore, il bloquait certaines mesures qu'il a dû annoncer pour la Flandre quatre jours plus tard.
Donc effectivement, il a complètement perdu la face. Mais on a vu aussi à ce moment-là qu'en fait, une logique fédérale avec des mesures diversifiées par région, ça n'a pas de sens.
Et même des nationalistes flamands, comme la N-VA, apparemment,
implicitement, le reconnaissent parce que sauf dans cette seule semaine fin octobre, ils ont toujours suivi la logique de prendre des mesures nationales.
Et donc ça, c'est, 'fin, c'est quand même quand on compare avec les autres pays fédéraux, assez surprenant en fait.
La phrase que vous citiez, en fait, date justement de cette semaine où on a fait ce petit expériment avec des mesures diversifiées et où tout le monde était d'accord que c'était pas vraiment à refaire parce que,
'fin, le signal donné à la population à ce moment-là, avec un nouveau leader politique chaque jour qui annonce de nouvelles mesures et plus personne comprenait quelles étaient les règles, dans quelle partie du pays.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est de noter que les mesures sont uniformes, uniformément nationales en Belgique, beaucoup plus que dans d'autres pays, même des pays encore unitaires d'ailleurs.
On va se quitter dans quelques instants. Est-ce que vous avez des prédictions pour-- j'aime beaucoup jouer à ce jeu-là.
Pour-- donc, nous sommes en 2020. Les prochaines élections fédérales et régionales seront en 2024. Est-ce que vous avez des prédictions aujourd'hui ?
Est-ce que vous voulez vous mouiller un petit peu sur
ce que vous pensez qu'il va survenir ? Déjà, première question : est-ce que le gouvernement Vivaldi, à votre avis,
tiendra jusqu'en 2024 ou bien est-ce que de nouveau, comme avec le gouvernement précédent, un parti finira par claquer la porte ?
Je suis pas grand fan de prédictions-
C'est pas votre jeu préféré ?
Bah, je trouve que les politologues sont pas des madames Soleil. Donc notre rôle, c'est plutôt d'expliquer certaines évolutions politiques, d'essayer de comprendre.
Prévoir, enfin, le comportement politique, comme tout comportement humain, est assez imprévisible, justement.
Donc, il y a beaucoup de choses qui, euh-- les grandes évolutions politiques n'ont été prédites correctement par presque personne, hein.
Personne n'avait prédit Trump, par exemple, sauf les Simpsons. Les bons politologues, en fait, sont les scénaristes des Simpsons.
Simpsons, c'était l'être.
Ouais. Mais bon, je-- néanmoins, voilà, je veux bien me prêter au jeu en même temps. J'aime bien les jeux.
Ce jeu, ouais, ça va.
Je crois qu'il y a quand même beaucoup de chance que le gouvernement Vivaldi tienne jusqu'en 2024,
parce que j'ai l'impression que surtout du côté flamand, chez les partis flamands, même s'il y avait une certaine ou une grande hésitation chez certains partis pour aller dans ce gouvernement,
je crois que maintenant, ils ont, comme on dit en néerlandais, de knop omdraaien, donc tourner le bouton-
Ouais, c'est ça, ouais
...et qu'ils se disent : « Voilà, maintenant, on y est. Donc là, on doit vraiment y aller. On doit plus hésiter, on doit vraiment s'engager dans ce projet.
» Et ce qu'on a vu quand même jusqu'ici, mais bon, ça fait que deux, trois mois, c'est que du côté flamand, mais je dis bien du côté flamand, chez les partis flamands, on est quand même dans une logique assez constructive, hein.
On voit qu'on essaye d'éviter les conflits entre les différents partenaires de coalition, les attaques typiques, et cetera.
Parce qu'on a peut-être aussi appris du gouvernement Michel, où là, les trois partis flamands ont constamment essayé de se déstabiliser, de s'attaquer, et cetera.
Ce qui n'a pas vraiment été un grand succès dans les urnes le 26 mai 2019. Donc, j'ai l'impression que du côté flamand, il y a vraiment cette volonté de donner aussi une image plus positive, plus constructive de la politique
à travers un gouvernement, voilà, où les partis travaillent ensemble, et cetera.
Bon, en réalité, c'est bien sûr pas toujours le cas. Il y a des vrais conflits, mais voilà, on peut essayer de pas trop communiquer dessus.
On peut essayer de donner une autre image. On peut aussi se défier, d'essayer d'éviter des conflits qui sont pas nécessaires, hein, voilà.
Et ça, c'est ce que je crois qu'on fait du côté flamand. Du côté francophone, par contre, c'est différent.
Là, j'ai l'impression qu'il y a une dynamique complètement différente où il y a vraiment un conflit énorme entre MR et PS qui se traduit aussi au sein du gouvernement.
Et c'est peut-être logique parce qu'en Flandre, les quatre partis qui sont dans le gouvernement font face à une opposition très forte.
Et donc, ça les réunit quand même aussi un petit peu, hein. Ils se disent : « Bon, si on tient pas ensemble, alors on va tous perdre.
» Donc voilà. Du côté francophone, les deux grands partis qui s'opposent sont tous les deux dans le gouvernement et donc ils continuent un peu à s'opposer à travers ce gouvernement.
L'instabilité, cette fois-ci, pourrait venir plus des partis francophones dans la Vivaldi que des partis flamands-
OK
...parce que du côté francophone, il y a presque pas d'opposition digne de ce nom pour réunir le MR, le PS et Ecolo.
C'est ça, oui. Et donc la personnalité de Georges-Louis Bouchez entre aussi en jeu puisque voilà-
Ça aussi, c'est un élément important.
C'est ça, oui. OK. Autre question : des personnalités au sein de cette majorité Vivaldi comme Alexander De Croo, comme Ecolo Groen, comme certaines voix au sein du mouvement réformateur
ont exprimé, ces dernières années, leur intérêt pour passer à un système de circonscription fédérale.
Est-ce que c'est aujourd'hui l'heure de passer à une circonscription fédérale ou bien est-ce que vous estimez que ça risque de ne pas arriver ?
En tout cas, je suis personnellement un partisan d'une circonscription fédérale, déjà depuis presque vingt ans.
Entretemps, j'ai défendu cette idée dans le débat public parce que, notab-- surtout pour des raisons de démocratie, en fait.
Parce que je crois qu'il y a un vrai
déficit démocratique dans notre pays. Les partis politiques peuvent gouverner tout un pays, peuvent prendre des décisions qui ont un impact sur onze millions de Belges,
mais ne doivent rendre de comptes que à la moitié de ces Belges, à la moitié du pays.
L'électeur, par contre, est gouverné par un tas de partis politiques, mais peut se prononcer que sur la moitié des partis politiques qui le gouvernent.
Donc, il y a quand même un problème. Par exemple, moi, j'habite à Anvers. Aux dernières élections, j'ai pas pu me prononcer, que ce soit favorablement ou défavorablement, sur le parti qui a livré le premier ministre, le MR de Charles Michel,
dans ce cas-ci.
L'électeur wallon, entre le milieu des années septante et 2012, n'a quasi jamais pu se prononcer sur le parti qui livrait le premier ministre non plus, parce que c'était toujours un parti flamand dans cette période-là.
Bon, là, ça pose quand même un, ça pose un vrai problème démocratique. Et donc, je crois que la circonscription fédérale serait une bonne réponse-
Pour revenir à la question principale
...à ce problème.
Est-ce que vous pensez que ça a une chance d'arriver vu que, voilà, je le disais, Alexander De Croo, dans la presse, ces dernières années, dit : « Ah, c'est quelque chose qu'il faut faire.
» Ecolo Groen aussi dit que, enfin, soutient cette idée. Donc, on a plusieurs acteurs qui défendent ça.
Ce n'était pas possible au gouvernement précédent, malgré, voilà, que Alexander De Croo était aussi vice-premier au sein du gouvernement Michel, mais voilà, c'était complètement bloqué par la N-VA, bien évidemment.
Aujourd'hui, il me semble que les ingrédients sont réunis, sauf peut-être le CD&V qui-- est-ce que c'est un parti confédéraliste ?
Est-ce que c'est un, voilà, il n'a pas trop envie d'employer ce mot parce que c'est un terme très très très associé à la N-VA.
Mais bref, toujours est-il qu'ils ont un rapport assez particulier au rôle des régions. Donc je, voilà, je repose la question : est-ce que vous pensez que ça a des chances d'arriver ?
Est-ce que les ingrédients sont là ?
Bah, la circonscription fédérale ne pourra être introduite que à travers une réforme de la Constitution.
Bon, pour ça, il faut une majorité des deux tiers. Et donc typiquement, c'est quelque chose qui se décidera ou ne se décidera pas dans le cadre d'une réforme de l'État, hein.
Donc si on arrive à une nouvelle négociation sur la réforme de l'État, par exemple après les élections de 2024 ou plus tard,
c'est probablement un dossier qui viendra sur la table parce que certains partis vont probablement le mettre sur la table.
Je pense notamment aux partis écologistes, aux partis libéraux. Le PS est officiellement pour une circonscription fédérale aussi.
Le SPA, ça a pas toujours été très clair, mais plutôt pour aussi
Mais la question dans une négociation en général, mais aussi notamment dans ce cas-ci, donc pour une réforme de l'État,
c'est toujours de savoir est-ce qu'il y a vraiment des partis pour qui une telle circonscription fédérale est vraiment une des grandes priorités ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des partis qui disent : « Voilà, nous, on veut bien faire des compromis, on veut bien apporter des votes pour une réforme de l'État, mais alors pour nous, la grande priorité, c'est vraiment la circonscription fédérale.
» Bon, si ça, c'est le cas, si par exemple, les partis écologistes dont on a besoin pour arriver à la majorité nécessaire pour cette réforme disent : « Bon, c'est soit avec la circonscription fédérale, soit c'est sans nous »,
alors ça a beaucoup de chance, effectivement, de se passer.
Bon, les écologistes devront alors faire d'autres concessions envers la N-VA et le CD&V, mais voilà, dans un paquet plus large, ça a des chances d'aboutir.
Si en même temps, les partis qui sont pour la circonscription fédérale disent : « Oui, oui, on est assez pour en théorie, mais bon, pour nous, ce n'est pas vraiment la priorité.
On a d'autres priorités. » Là, ça va pas se passer. Donc tout dépend, il suffit pas simplement d'ajouter le nombre de sièges de tous les partis qui sont pour et qui sont contre.
Non. Une négociation, c'est toujours donnant-donnant. Et voilà, la question est de savoir est-ce que pour suffisamment de partis, c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'ils vont vraiment défendre comme une priorité.
Mais donc avant tout ça-
Et là, je suis sceptique, c'est pas sûr.
Rien ne, rien ne jouait, ouais.
C'est aussi possible que d'autres partis mettent leur veto, que la N-VA, par exemple, dise : « Bon, ça, on veut pas du tout.
» Et alors, à nouveau, il faudra voir. Est-ce que d'autres partis disent : « Oui, mais alors bon, on fait pas de réforme parce que nous, pour nous, c'est essentiel.
» Tout ça n'est pas encore à cent pour cent clair, mais je constate quand même, je suis ce débat déjà depuis très longtemps.
D'ailleurs, j'ai aussi écrit pour le CRISP toute une historique de l'idée de circonscription fédérale en Belgique depuis les années 70, où ça a parfois déjà été suggéré par certains.
L'idée a quand même vraiment
fait tout un chemin entre temps, hein. Je me rappelle, il y a vingt ans, quand j'en parlais parfois dans une interview, on me regardait un peu comme un académique, justement, dans sa tour d'ivoire, déconnecté de la réalité du terrain.
Ouais, c'est une idée d'académique théorique. Bon, entre temps, voilà, y a quand même beaucoup de figures politiques, il y a beaucoup de partis politiques qui ont ça dans leur programme.
Il y a beaucoup d'intellectuels qui ont défendu ça. Donc, on a quand même vraiment avancé dans le débat sociétal.
Très bien. Ben, je pense que ça conclut magnifiquement notre entretien. Merci beaucoup pour ce moment passé ensemble.
C'était avec grand plaisir. Ça fait toujours plaisir de pouvoir aller un peu plus au fond des choses, de prendre son temps, ce qui n'est pas toujours facile dans les médias où on doit faire un quote de vingt secondes pour un journal télévisé.
Ouais, ouais. Tout le plaisir pour moi. Et du coup, je vous dis à dans deux semaines pour un prochain épisode. Au revoir.
Vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à écouter Septante Minutes Avec et je vous remercie pour votre soutien. Comme je le disais en intro, je suis très pris en ce moment, pas énormément de temps libre.
Je sais toujours pas qui je vais inviter dans deux semaines. J'ai pas mal d'idées de sujets que je pourrais traiter, hein.
J'ai noté évidemment, suite à l'actualité, la question de la police, mais difficile de savoir exactement qui inviter, comment traiter cette question.
C'est très-- c'est un débat très polarisé et qui peut facilement devenir assez caricatural. C'est compliqué. J'ai noté quelques idées d'intellectuels, quelques idées de professeurs à l'ULB,
quelques idées de politiciens belges, politiciennes belges.
Donc voilà, des choses à clarifier, des sujets à explorer, mais voilà, je-- pour l'instant, je ne sais pas encore.
Et si ça se trouve, personne ne sera dispo. Donc voilà, vous êtes prévenus. N'oubliez pas de suivre Septante Minutes Avec sur les réseaux sociaux et sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée.
Et on se retrouve très vite pour d'autres formidables interviews. Bisous, bye bye, prenez soin de vous.